what the white community doesn't
understand about being a person of color
in this nation is that there are daily
slights
michelle obama opening up about her own
experiences with racism
on the latest episode of the michelle
obama podcast
in our workplaces where people talk over
you or people don't even see you
the 56-year-old author and podcast host
chats with a few of her long-time
pals and details her encounters with
racism
during her time as flotus a role she
held from 2009 to 2017
when her husband barack obama was
president
we had just finished the taken the girls
to a soccer game we were
stopping to get ice cream and i
had told the secret service to stand
back because we were trying to be
normal trying to go in of course the
girls are her daughters
malia and sasha who are now 22 and 19
respectively
there was a line and once again when i'm
just a black woman
i noticed that white people don't even
see me they're not even looking at me
and a white woman cuts right in front of
us to order
like she didn't even see us and the
girl behind the counter almost took her
order so i stepped up and i said
excuse me as you don't see us
four people standing right here you just
jumped in line according to michelle the
woman didn't apologize
and never even looked her in the eyes
she didn't know it was me
all she saw was a black person or a
group of black people or maybe she
didn't even see
that because we were that invisible
michelle said she could tell a bunch of
stories like that that even with her
worldwide fame she's been treated as
invisible
people will come up and pet my dogs
but will not look me in the eye they
don't know it's me
that that is so telling of how
white america views people who are not
like them
you know we don't exist and
when we do exist we exist as a threat
and that that's exhausting
but this isn't the first time michelle
has opened up about her personal
experience with discrimination
in her netflix documentary becoming she
recalled the pressure of being the first
black first lady
and reflected on the racist stereotypes
and personal attacks she faced while
campaigning
the only thing i can do is share that
that does hurt
because if we walk around pretending
like it doesn't hurt the perpetrators
just say oh i was just joking
it's just politics it's like no no no no
that that changes the shape of a
person's soul
in an interview with oprah she revealed
how she cried for hours on the
ceremonial final flight out of
washington after eight years in the
white house
we got on air force one and when i got
on the plane
i think i sobbed you did
for 30 minutes and
i think it was just the release of eight
years
of trying to do everything perfectly
and in her 2018 memoir michelle says she
felt racism as a student at harvard and
princeton she shared that her first
roommate switched dorms after learning
she was black
her mother a school teacher from new
orleans had been so appalled that her
daughter had been assigned a black
roommate
that she'd badgered the university to
separate us
but in the podcast michelle says the one
thing that's helped her get through the
difficult times
her friends specifically her black
female friends
my girlfriend group while it is diverse
it has been so important for me to have
black women in my crew
throughout my life professionally
because there's just a certain relief
that comes when you don't have to walk
into your friend group and explain
yourself
and she says that those pals are even
more important to her
amid the current black lives matter
movement my group
of female friends aren't calling me to
say what can i do you guys are calling
me to say how you doing girl
you know let's talk